could stargate's pre-production already
have started I've heard a couple of
rumors that make it sound like some work
a little bit might have already actually
been done
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so we talk about Stargate a bit on this
channel occasionally sometimes not often
and we've been able to bring you lots of
big exclusives over the last couple of
years as we build up towards the new
Stargate series movie Whatever Amazon
decide to finally do
but there are a couple of rumors
knocking around at the moment that
suggest Amazon might have already
actually started doing some of the early
pre-production work now we have heard
rumors before
that Mark Fergus um from penguin and
Parker is already lined up to do a lot
of the development work we've heard that
there may be a director already lined up
we've heard that there is actually a
script knocking around and we believe
the plan is still to do a cinematic
movie now we also finally believe that
back in March
um Claudia Valentini who is the new head
of film at Amazon and MGM has actually
ordered the project to begin
Now by my I mean Jennifer salki the head
of actual Prime Studios actually
instructed her to begin work on the
RoboCop reboot the
um Legally Blonde three project which I
don't want to watch
um a couple of things for creed and
finally Stargate
so we think that's work has started but
we've been waiting for something a
little bit more concrete it's actually
anything getting done well we did hear a
lot of rumors again that this was going
to be announced as San Diego Comic-Con
but when Amazon Executives realize
actually the right to strike and the
actors were going to go on strike back
as early as March this year those plans
were put on pause there were no
preparation Works done for anything to
be released at San Diego Comic-Con I
know there have been rumors about um
some things were get done and some
things were lined up but I'm told
they're not true so
no plans in place to announce just yet
and everything is on pause
but why do I say there might have been
some early pre-production work done well
I've heard a couple of rumors from a
couple of different sources now so I
feel like it's fair to share well for
one I heard recently that a German
special effects company was actually
contracted to do some CGI work for an
unspecified MGM project that work was
supposed to be done
um September through to November or
December this year just gone so it
should be starting now basically
um and that there was further contracts
etc for sort of post-effects work to be
done so that would have been a German
company doing the CGI potentially for
Stargate now we don't believe that would
be RoboCop because even though that is
actually also planned and penned in we
and may actually be a little bit further
down the line than Stargate
that is looking like that's going to be
filmed in the US and not in Europe
another reason though why we think that
that might have been Stargate that was
being lined up and I should say that
that contract now has been pushed back
um there is no CGI work being done right
now and there's no plan to obviously
because of the strikes but because of
another rumor as well the other rumor
being that actually some very early
stage work and pre-production work might
have been done in Austria now this comes
from a source that actually believes
they might have seen a mock-up of the
Stargate now the source was very clear
to me that he was not 100 certain what
he was actually looking at and he really
came to me quite gentle he says it at
the time when he saw it he really wasn't
sure at all what he was looking at he
didn't know Stargate was actually going
to be um revived when he came back he
then sort of Googled us and found
Sidetrack and when he started watching
our videos he sort of put two and two
together and decided to get in touch
with us so he's basically had to say
look I'm not swearing on this do not put
my hand on a Bible
but I think I might have actually seen
the early stage we're getting done now
what would have you actually seen would
he actually looks of sets being built
I've spoken to another source who has
said yes he believes and he knows in
fact that some money has been spent
already on the Stargate project and he
knows that that spending is in the
millions now that shouldn't really be a
surprise because the He-man project that
got canceled just about a month ago had
actually had 30 million pounds already
spent on it in development work and
getting certain things ready for filming
no film had been done but they'd already
managed to spend that much money so the
fact that the Stargate project has
already spent Millions shouldn't really
surprise us
but would it be sets actually that were
being built my guy says probably not
what he probably saw even if it was the
Stargate was actually early mock-ups so
it would be stuff that they would build
they would they would be built basically
very cheaply very quickly they wouldn't
be sort of digital cinema quality but
the idea is to start getting an idea of
what sort of thing they would do it
would be an early mock-up that they then
use to then build the proper full-scale
set later this says this is quite a
common thing they do when they're sort
of building up and getting ready to
actually begin filming a lot of the time
this work will be done before anything's
announced it's very much done as a
preparation for further work it says
also practically the guys that then
build these massive sets and don't
forget all the sets have to be built
well before filming starts all of these
guys do need to do their mock-ups and
things to try to figure out how certain
things will work for example if the
Stargate has moved in Parts they need to
figure out how to do that so
if the source is correct and actually
what he did see was this early
preliminary work done for the Stargate
film movie whatever
it is very very plausible it's very
possible that that is exactly what this
person saw in that case it does look
like the Stargate movie might actually
be filmed in Eastern Europe now I spoke
to another source and they said look I
don't know anything about that but MGM
has done a lot of projects in Eastern
Europe over the last few years they've
got a lot of resources over there
they've got a lot of connections over
there they know the people that work
there they know the sort of level of the
local Tradesmen the people that can
build the sets Etc lighting Engineers
blah blah blah so it would not surprise
that person at all and this is somebody
that knows MGM very very well if
actually yes Stargate was going to be
filmed and produced in Eastern Europe
and obviously then connecting that back
to the German special effects company
all of a sudden we're getting lots of
crumbs that are making up a bigger
picture maybe there's a reason why this
episode and these videos are called
Rumor Mill by the way we're very much in
rumor territory I should also say that
another source completely separately
from these sources came to me and
basically said the same thing again
there were bits they didn't know and
we've had to sort of try to piece that
puzzle together a little bit but they
completely separately basically repeated
what I was being told that this will be
filmed in Europe that some work is
already being done and actually they
have already spent millions in
development
so it looks like if it wasn't for the
strike we probably would have got an
announcement at San Diego Comic-Con and
we would have maybe got the filming
started in the late summer Early Autumn
like we were told we would earlier in
the year because in advance what we
believed that's filming was supposed to
start by Christmas
and if that was true then all of this
preliminary work would need to have been
done and this work does take months so
just maybe a source here has stumbled on
quite a big secret and I've actually
seen the early stages of the Stargate
movie getting made
if so I'm very happy and I'm really just
hoping that this strike can end very
quickly that we can get that official
announcement we're desperately waiting
for and that some of these rumors can
turn into facts but guys give the
comments and tell me what you think is
this just more smoke but is there a fire
do you actually think that Eastern
Europe is probably a sensible place for
MGM to actually film this project
Amazon have already shown that they want
to become an international filmmaker and
they want to make stuff all over the
world they don't want to make things in
Hollywood as much so again does this
make sense get into the comments and
tell me what you think
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where most of our new
videos appear first and for a small
contribution that really supports a
channel you get to see them about the
adverts you can also follow all of these
links they're in the description as well
including our new website
sidetrack.co.uk where we produce stories
related to all of these videos and we
give you just that little bit more to
chew on
please as always stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]